hi I'm Jane levy I'm here with BuzzFeed
and I'm gonna tell you about my first
time first horror movie you ever watched
I think jaws should count as a horror
movie it's so scary
I watched it when I was way too young I
think I was five or six there was this
basement room at my aunt's house that
was clearly unsupervised and I was
traumatized by jaws and I still don't go
in the ocean first song you filmed for
Zoey's extraordinary playlist all I do
is win is that possible I think that was
our first number first song you learned
all the words - well chickadee China the
Chinese chicken have a drumstick in your
brain stop sticking something with the
lights off clearly I know all the words
but I did know them when I was in fourth
grade first Liberty crush
there are many Jonathan Taylor Thomas or
whatever first thing you do on your
phone when you wake up oh god I don't
want to admit it I think I might check
my Instagram that is so sad I'm changing
my life forever and I'm never checking
my Instagram when I first wake up ever
again first memory filming with Skylar
Astin on Zoey's extraordinary playlist
probably something I can't share on
camera probably has something to do with
talking Skylar is such a fun person to
talk about the first project of yours
you would have rewatch right now no
thanks first item you took from a set
I took the chainsaw from the Evil Dead
movie I have it in my storage facility
in LA cut anyone wants it first time
you're starstruck it might have been
when I met Kyle McLaughlin I held his
hands he held it back first impressions
of Lauren Graham Peter Gallagher I love
both of those guys Peter my first
impression was watching him on the OC
and I felt like he was my dad and Lauren
I can't remember the first time I met
Lauren but it was before we worked I was
always extraordinary playlist because we
share a mutual best friend and me
Whitman I think I always just thought
Lauren was very chic first wild fan
experience I was in New Zealand this
isn't really a fan story but shooting
Evil Dead in New Zealand and some
he was like you that girl from suburban
Ovilus or whatever anyone thought
Suburgatory was called and I was like
yeah and he was like a campy and I was
like why not and he was like because
you're in my TV you're so like I was
like what the I guess you're saying I
looked really buff on TV and I looked
like a squirt in person or something
first onscreen kiss was with Cameron
Monaghan on shameless
when I played Mandy in the first season
before I was replaced by another actress
because I got another job not because I
was fired but um yeah I kissed him he
didn't want to kiss me back because his
character was gay and he told me in the
next that I would be his beard that's
cool first job I was a pizza delivery
girl in high school for Guerin Gilley's
pizzeria and Fairfax California first
time you knew you were famous I don't
really think I'm famous but the other
day at the pet store I went buy cat food
and litter and they were like levy led
why and I was like yes first role you
really wanted but didn't get I tested
for an Alan Ball pilot when I first got
to LA that didn't end up becoming a
series but I really wanted to first kiss
this boy when I was young took me behind
a wall and told me to spit in my hand
and he spit in his hand and we switched
our phones together and he told me we
kissed first audition I remember my very
first audition but it was in New York
when I lived in New York still and I
don't think I got the part actually I
know I didn't get the part that was so
fun thanks for playing with me I'm Jane
levy make sure to watch Zoey's
extraordinary playlist Sundays on NBC
and screaming
[Music]